hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem nein video werfen
natürlich geht es gut es bisschen
eigentlich gerade deswegen versuche ich
schnell zu hören und ein bisschen schief
ist auch noch ich versuche mich kurz
ausdrücken wir befinden uns hier gerade
bei media markt kann man hinter mir
glaube ich ganz gut sehen wir mal ich
habe mir nämlich eine kleine challenge
überlegt oder ich wollte auf jeden fall
dazu ein video machen ich habe ja schon
oft gesagt es gibt ein adventskalender
und alles dieses jahr der ja auch schon
angefangen hat am zweiten dezember also
es gibt in jedem video wirklich ne fette
verlosung ich habe schon richtig viele
sachen aber jetzt wollte ich auf jeden
fall noch von meinem eigenen geld
einiges zu tun und deswegen habe ich mal
wieder bei und ich habe mir gedacht du
darfst jetzt gleich fünf minuten wenn
das nicht reicht machen wir sieben
minuten raus dadurch gehen und einfach
alles mitnehmen was so cool findest und
was du denkst dir persönlich gefällt und
was meinen zuschauern auch gefallen
könnte die jungs und mädels genau
natürlich und ich habe aber eine
obergrenze gesetzt und zwar mehr als
3000 euro darfst du bitte nicht ausgehen
bis 3000 euro hier hab ich davon auch
was verlosen
für meine weil ich so nett bin und heute
die spendierhosen habe natürlich eine
sache darfst du dir aussuchen die darfst
du dann berlin ruft an jetzt hat mich
merlin gerade angerufen wegen den
laptops ihr habt ja ich habe per laptop
schnell wenn du das video noch nicht
gesehen habe zeigt auf jeden fall ab
also eine sache darfst du dann für dich
behalten und auf demenz haben verlosen
der rest kommt alles bei mir auf youtube
und wir gehen jetzt rein und hier viel
glück
so marie auf die plätze fertig los
das sieht doch schon mal gut aus fosters
[Musik]
aber dass er so einen kleinen ja egal
die sind gut aus weitergeht du hast
du hast ein bisschen zeitdruck das musst
du wissen er weiter geht's
[Musik]
also ich glaube dass sie sich langsam
aus was du machst
das ist aber kaka oder ach so ich will
dich nicht beeinflussen das ist einfach
nur deine meinung vielleicht freut sich
daher jemand darüber
ja dann weiter jetzt
schon mal hier sind doch
was haben wir denn hier
tastaturen sind dass nur
du musst es gut aufteilen
also ich sage am ende hast du absolut
fast gar nicht so wie du wie du jetzt
gerade an die sache ran gehst
ja dann lasst uns besser liegen weil das
kostet safe ziemlich viel dann doch
jemand einfachen 12
was kostet das
also rein wird schon passen nur weil man
jetzt
du hast zeit wird man dann
das interessiert sie gar nicht
sportiver mal ganz entspannt gelangen
die hier um nahrung ist schon ein
fernseher den kannst du doch gut in
einen kleinen mini core plattform hier
sind wir absolut in der richtigen
abteilung sonst kannst du auch ein
auswählen und wir holen jahre später
noch dazu im fernsehen ist auch geld
kommt fernseher aussuchen schnell
zeitdruck
was das denn
am besten ein bisschen klein weil ich
habe sonst angst ist das nicht ins auto
passt so einer wird rein passen hier
kostet der spaß 599
da gibt's sonst auch noch kleinere da
steht das
welchen den da steht der ist glaube ich
da passiert nicht ins auto passt wir
müssen wenn da nur den hinnehmen
den werden wir uns weiter geht's
du hast du übrigens schon zwei minuten
40 also eigentlich ist schon mehr als
die hälfte rum vielleicht airports oder
so dass es kommt immer gut airports und
ein iphone ich weiß nicht ob das ist
aber hier ein kleines gerät alter was
ein riesenfernseher
wir sind kopfhörer
[Musik]
ach so das ist nur das case
hier sind hier sind airports pro hier
hier hier hier kannst du dich von deinem
mehrere mitkommen du hast du hast ja
noch ordentlich im park eine monster
12 kommt kommt rein damit
rollvi du meinst ist 41
ok weiter
[Musik]
wir sind
ok wird gleich so jetzt nicht wie vom
partei verantwortung lassen wir die
sketche den kriegen wir nicht mit dem
mann ist mit der kamera willst du nicht
nur ein iphone
wir sind jetzt gerade schon weil vier
minuten 28
eigentlich seien counter schon gleich
vorbei komme ich geb dir noch eine
minute extra
[Musik]
mai von 12 noch mit
wenn das mal kein schwarz gibt seine
zeit ist abgelaufen hatten gewiss durch
so der verkäufer wollte noch sein
eigenes handy an drehen weil ich hier so
jetzt so viel einkaufen was ist dafür
eine hat mainz verpasste unverrückbar
gerne
auch das ist sonst müssen wir immer wenn
fragen also wir haben echt viel
abgetestet hier ich bin absolut
zufrieden wir suchen jetzt schon
verkäufer noch der uns hier in guten
fernseher noch an dreht und wir haben
uns jetzt hier seinen großen könnte an
klatschen lassen
lösen wir das zu hause auf was alles
geholt haben soll ich weiter fehlen
glaube dass ich den fernseher gleich auf
dem schoß themen
check unbedingt noch mal ein alex lokal
ab da gibt es aktuell täglich um 20 30
coole streams und ja ich würde mich
freuen wir noch später vorbeischaut so
leute hat doch optimal geklappt weiß wie
viel soll der fernseher hat
108 cm durchmesser smardtv von lg haben
wir uns doch gerade um entschieden weil
er meint ist einfach besser und er hat
jetzt auch perfekt ins auto gepasst also
ich bin so zufrieden es hat richtig gut
funktioniert was es gut gemacht dank
innerhalb von sechs minuten eine minute
gab's für ein raunen wir die ganze zeit
von den verkäufern angequatscht wegen
der garantie genau wir zeigen euch
einfach einmal alle sachen bei mir zu
hause sind deswegen
sollte man meinen
wir haben alles gerade schon ausgeladen
der fernseher hat also gerade
reingebracht und jetzt wo wir noch mal
ein kurzer überblick hier geben was die
wunderbare losfee marie dann alles so
eingekauft hat wir haben jetzt unseren
bezahlt also ich hätte sogar gedacht es
wird teurer ist schon eigentlich preis
2.500
jetzt sagt da nicht schon an dass hier
interniert ist auf jeden fall jetzt die
nachricht ja jetzt nix wenn es nun
arbeiten dann musste daraufhin
nur jetzt sieht man was oder dann hätte
ich nicht mehr ich habe ja auch so
die ganze ecke hinter mir hat man gesagt
werde ich habe das rennen ausgewählt von
6521 euro wobei ungefähr 600 euro der
produkte werden einmal gebündelt so der
alex ministerin box die können dann auch
einer gewinnen weil ich habe keinen bock
das alles einzeln rauszustellen das wäre
viel zu viel arbeit und das ist jetzt
auch nichts was so mega kasse wie zb das
iphone und wir haben ja einmal das
iphone 12 gekauft hinweis finde ich am
schönsten einigt ich habe auch mal
helfen weil ich hab das an ausgesuchten
jaja so maria das aussuchen dann haben
wir hier noch das iphone achters das
hatte ich schon der hinweis dann haben
wir hier vier paar er trotz darin darfst
du ein verlosen fünf davon darfst du ein
verlosen ein paar natürlich und hier
haben wir dann noch ein ipad mini muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen das hätte ich
nicht genommen aber das war ja deine
entscheidung ist ja auch in ordnung weil
ich finde beide seiten mit mini da kann
man sich auch gleich ein iphone holen
oder so klein wieder lustig bande also
ich finde es von cool ist ein größerer
bildschirm und dann habe jedoch eine
mentale switch wie fahrlässig handeln
dachte ich kurz das zu meiner
verteidigung sagen noch leute die farbe
ist hässlich aber ich habe das extra
genommen weil bei den anderen war kein
spiel dabei und bei dem war an dem may
casting bei
und dahinter das ultra hd smart tvs
108 cm durchmesser schönes gerät hat wie
gesagt sogar ins auge gefasst und ja es
kommen aber auch noch sachen es ist noch
nicht alles da also das gewinnspiel die
richtig essen kann heute ist natürlich
auch ein video was werden heute
herauskommen marie du darfst dir
aussuchen was heute verlost wird an die
leute
heute wird das chemie herrn lieb verlost
das schaue mir ja gut das kann man wie
immer das show me tonight super gerät
kompatibel
ich habe das schon mal ein bisschen
getestet und so das ist auf jeden fall
absolut geile kamera das könnte dann
heute gewinnen einfach irgendein
kommentar schreiben und ich suche dann
einen raus die kommentare werden immer
dann angepinnt also der gewinner fährt
angepinnt unter dem video habe ich mir
so überlegt also schaut genau wozu mal
rein ob ihr angepinnt wurdet ich glaube
man kriegt aber auch eine
benachrichtigung das war's dann heute
wir sehen uns überholen wieder gibt's
neues video und da wird dann auch wieder
was geiles raushauen ihr müsst auf jeden
fall abonnent sein dafür ist der ganz
klare überall so aber ist ja nur ein
kleiner was macht man eigentlich wenn
man gewonnen hat schreibt man geht dann
muss ich scharf versucht dann die leute
zu kontaktieren aber wie gesagt deswegen
guckt mal auch irgendwo angepinnt wurde
von mir